each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you all for coming it's my great
pleasure to introduce dr. wick bacilli
from the University of Maryland which
has been one of the pioneers in the
field of empirical software engineering
for almost three decades now he's
actually going to talk to us about the
role of empirical study in software
engineering today
thank you so I'm at the University of
Maryland where I have been for 37 years
and I'm also representing fraunhofer
sena Maryland which is about it it's
about eight nine years old began at 1997
um so some of the work and I'm well let
me begin let me begin with this setting
a context so you know where I'm coming
from and where I'm going going to be
going soft the first is an obvious
statement i believe software engineering
is an engineering discipline i want to
underline engineering in both places so
that that we need to understand the
products and the processes in the
relationship between them and we assume
there is one sometimes I think we act as
though there isn't a relationship
between them that is we worry about
optimizing a process independent of the
product I mean the goal the ultimate
goal is to understand if you if you want
certain product characteristics what
processes you have to put in place to
give you those product characteristics
we need to experiment so if we're still
developed by human which that so we're
talking about human based studies we
need to experiment analyze and
synthesize knowledge from what we've
learned in terms of we have ideas that
we think will work try them out and see
what happens but try them out in a
rational way and collect the data and
collect the information that says you
have some not you've built some
knowledge out of what you've just done
and we need to package your model that
knowledge for use and for evolution and
we need to recognize well he has his my
perspective if you really believe all
those things I have on that slide it
changes completely the way you think
about software development their example
so I'm teaching someone how to program I
say that here's what we think is right
but think about it yourself and see if
we can try other ideas okay is is this
kind of design technique useful for the
affected with a particular application
you're working on it may be it may not
be figure it out
we very often teach back freshman
classes as though his truth that i'm
giving you instead of here's an idea and
figure out what really happens with it
so it's that same is about work anytime
you're doing anything it's always a qui
should always be questioning and trying
to understand to collect data to
understand whether or not what you're
doing is right or not so this concept of
understanding a discipline which is true
for all disciplines the concepts of
observation and model building and
experimentation they're they're
perfectly natural phenomenon their
activities people always do and learning
involves the encapsulation of knowledge
checking of our knowledge that our
knowledge is correct and evolving it
over time okay that's this empirical
paradigm is how all physical and social
sciences work as a matter of fact the
basis of how they do anything so whether
i'm talking with medicine or physics or
manufacturing they all have this feat
feedback mechanism about observation and
learning and change and software
engineering is supposed to have a two
but we forgot it somewhere along the way
we forgot about this part of the process
because we're running so fast to try
something new that we didn't work we're
beginning to worry about what does it
really work how does it work under what
conditions does it work when do I have
to change and try a different
combination of things what's the
difference then physics and medicine and
manufacturing is what's the difference
between physics and medicine okay the
kinds of experiments you do the kinds of
things you're observing the kinds of
techniques you can do for model building
are very different I mean manufacturing
I have the same process replicated over
and over and over again so I could build
good data models based on the knowledge
and information I capture from that
process it's not so clear with medicine
because things are a little bit
different okay but it's there's humans
it's a human element and so I have
sometimes a softer kind of experimental
paradigm that I'm making
so in physics it's a pretty rigorous
paradigm but there's an interesting
thing about physics as I can't change
the universe so what I'm studying is
very different to many cases where in
manufacturing the goal is to change the
universe that I'm that I'm dealing with
so although the underlying underpinnings
of the paradigms are the same there they
act differently you'll find different
methods and mechanisms for each of them
and we have to worry about what are the
right ones for software engineering so
I'm going to define empirical software
engineering it involves the scientific
use of quantitative and qualitative data
to understand and improve the software
product software development process and
software management so if it's an
empirical study area it needs deauxma it
needs laboratories the only place at
laboratories exist are in the real world
where people actually build software the
only place you can you can do them we
sometimes simulate them with studies we
do with students but sometimes we're
interested in novice programs how do
they have they evolved how do they
develop but research needs laboratories
to observe manipulate the variables the
only exists where developers build real
systems and the other hand development
needs to understand how to build those
systems better so they need research to
provide the models that tell them under
what conditions they should do what and
how so the point here is that research
and development in the software domain
is really a synergistic relationship
that requires a working relationship
between industry and academia or in
product development and research
organizations
so let me be clear about what i mean by
the kinds of knowledge we want to have a
software organization needs to ask
what's the right combination of
technical and managerial solutions for
the problem at hand okay what are the
right set of processes for that business
how are they tailored for the particular
project how do we how do they learn from
the success and failures and how do we
demonstrate sustained measurable
improvement in what we're doing so those
are the questions we should be asking
and part of the problem is one size
doesn't fit all so we need to be able to
manipulate process when do you use one
kind of process versus when to use
another okay if the requirements are
changing all the time that's very
different from something where I really
understand what the requirements look
like this is there's a simple example
but there's just lots and lots of
variables that change everything we're
going to do so let me give some examples
of studies that one can perform here's a
hey under specified conditions I have
that on the top techniques selection
guidance peer reviews are more effective
than functional testing for false of
omission and incorrect specification is
some studies in at Maryland and
University of Southern California that
support that that belief wow that's a
really important statement what it says
is number one if I know something about
my anticipated defect patterns then I
know how to manipulate my process to
maximize its its effect okay on the
other hand functional testing is more
effective than reviews for false of
numerical approximations and control
flow you go again same thing I how do i
balance reviews and testing and put them
together that is what do I know about my
environment what can I anticipate and
how do i how do i check what needs to be
done we can go further we can if we're
studying those particular techniques in
a particular environment there are
studies that say for example for
reviewer with average experience a
procedural approach to defect detection
such as
particular organized type of reading is
more effective than a less procedural
one and notice this what this says in
the in the middle this is true for aha
for someone with average experience if
you think about it as a bell curve if
someone's really exceptional they have
their own internal model and we don't
know what it is but they're doing better
and if someone's really bad no matter
what you give them it's not going to
work but for the majority of people in
the middle domain that really has an
effect given his another one procedural
inspections based upon specific goals
will find defects related to those goals
so inspections can be and should be
customized okay that's when I really
look at that segment ago it's so obvious
why did he say that well he said that
because we don't customize inspections
in general people just take this temp
high level template say okay here's what
you do remember I favorite line is home
and says you read you know here's a
piece of reading wow there's a billion
kinds of reading I can do what's the
right kind of reading for requirements
or code or whatever i'm dealing with
they got to be different hey i got to
have different reasons for doing that
reading what am I looking for is that is
that is that supported by the process
like defined okay readers of software
artifacts are more effective in
uncovering defects when they use
different focused approaches so if you
take multiple views at the same product
where there's different ways to do the
reading you do better than if everybody
does the same thing and surely better
than if you just read
okay so some basic concepts gives you
that sort of says what it is I'm trying
to look for what it is we need to figure
out when we're doing all this so some
basic concepts that we've made use of in
primm p racal software engineering or
things like the quality improvement
paradigm which is really just the
scientific method sort of adapted for
software and software is a little
different than manufacturing so it looks
like the scientific method it looks a
little bit like plan do check act though
so they're all the basic concepts are
the same what's different about them is
the thing they're looking at and
therefore things change for that reason
we use the gold question metric para
dining which is just an approach for
establishing project and corporate goals
and a mechanism for measuring against
those goals so is a simple statement
that says we collect data white what
data should we collect and the answer
should be what do you want to know so it
sounds obvious but very often i have
seen in many many organizations people
collecting data and didn't think about
what they wanted to know they just
wanted to know the data and what they
really want is information and knowledge
and the last piece is the society of an
experienced factory we're going to learn
how do we start to build that knowledge
into something and you and evolve it how
do we do the analysis and synthesis of
the knowledge that we're collecting in
that in this process so the quality
improvement paradigm is sort of this
this kind of a cycle and here's what
makes it a little different it's really
a two-loop cycle there's an outer loop
and this outer loop talks about first
characterizing and understanding what's
the world you're living in what's the
world in fact for this particular
product versus that particular product
they're probably different do we know
what processes we have in place do we
know what kinds of defects we make what
are the problems we're what's the effort
being spent where is it being spent
before I know it do anything fancy I
want to know where I am and the truth is
I'm always in a different place
depending
from shortly from company from company
but very often even from product to
product and then I want to set my goals
what if I want to cheat given where I am
what is it I want to be able to achieve
so I can set my goals with with the
right kind of knowledge and then I
choose the processes and techniques and
methods and tools that I want to use so
I build my project plan about how I'm
going to execute what it is I'm going to
do but that plan is built based on my
goals and based on an understanding of
the environment that I'm living in and
then I do it i execute that process and
analyze the results that here's the
project development I provide feedback
so i can constantly evolve within that
but then when i'm done i analyze the
results and package and store it in as
part of my experience because it's now
changing my understanding in the
environment i'm living in this was a
giant data point or sets of data points
which I try and put into the into the
into my knowledge base okay and see
whether or not it works the experience
factor is just is just the concept of a
learning organization okay it's the idea
that if I think about projects what I'm
really seeing is and here where the
steps of the improvement paradigm I
think about characterizing setting goals
and choosing process and if if this
knowledge base okay XP recorded
experience-based I'll say that why in a
minute is picking up information about
what's going on and says oh in the past
here's what we've done or here's what
you need or here's your models and
here's the things you need to use so we
can build for you for this project a
good execution plan and then you can
execute it so there's an interaction
that's going on here an interaction
between this and what will and this
learning organization which supports the
information that you now know when you
come down here it monitors that project
as it's being executed because what you
told it may have been a lie things
change they were in exactly the way we
thought they were going to be so we want
to be able to constantly have sort of
feedback and analysis of what's going on
in that process but while we're getting
that feedback and analysis to support
the project we're also building
knowledge for the organization
we're learning what works and doesn't
work so I want to I can analyze and
package this is my analysis and
synthesis process where I can analyze
and package generalized Taylor formal
light formula formalize disseminate and
put this in an experience base so that
the knowledge is being built over time I
add it back I constantly taking what I
haven't and meshing it with what I've
already learned so now I understand
which context variables for example
change the effects of a particular
process I I or I have more evidence that
this is this is really a good approach
on under the following sets of
conditions and then so when the next
project comes along I can make change
for it so what's happening here the
project this is this we've always done
there's a project coming through we may
not have been this planned as this but
project coming through out the other end
and this is really an organization
that's trying to build knowledge about
how this organization has worked in the
past and what it what it successes and
failures are and how it might make
changes to them so the reason for the
term experienced factory is it's based
on experience within the in particular
organization so so whenever you change
even if I try something brand-new I want
to understand how it works against what
I've applied before so this is one more
point to make an issue here what's
coming down the side of the of the slide
is what what what you do with the
project organization does its problem
solving and the activities are
decomposing a problem into simpler ones
instantiating potential solutions design
implementation process validation and
verification its product delivery within
schedule and cost and that's the key
here you want to be able to build that
product out that if that product out the
door think about it it's sort of
top-down how are you going through this
process and putting it together what's
going on in the experience factory
you're you're you're identifying
different solutions and unifying and
redefining problems you're going
bottom-up is what you're doing you're
taking low level knowledge and saying oh
you know it works here here's where I
can build a better model you're
generalizing formalizing you're going
through an analysis synthesis process
you're experimenting because you're
observing what's going on on that end of
the process and you're what you have is
experienced and recommendation delivery
back to projects this represents in some
sense what the organization knows that
this at any given point in time about
their business this is the learning
organization as I said this is bottom-up
that's top-down point I want to make a
couple points here none of these
activities are side effects of those
activities you can't even do them both
at the same time so it requires
different people doing this than doing
that you can't be at the same time
building a product and stepping back
yourself and analyzing what just
happened and whether it's a reasonable
thing or not so it's a separate activity
going on that from this and I'd like to
make the following argument it's very
rare you see this exists at all so if
this isn't happening there's no
observation going on and we're not
learning from project to project we're
just we learn as individuals but we
don't learn as an organization and
that's really the fundamental thing if
you but you have to build better and
better knowledge about how you build
software so for good 25 years we
developed these concept this paradigm
working with NASA Goddard and the thing
called the software engineering lab
which had three components to it was
NASA Goddard computer sciences
corporation who with a primary
contractor and the University of
Maryland who was trying to put these
mechanisms together and we built an
experience factory in fact we evolved
I'd like to be evolved to an experience
factory we had this there's a date
summer in the slide but I can't find it
but oh here is but this is this was
about 1994-95 it was it had about 275 to
300 developers at had 5 25 people about
six
10 active projects at any given time
compared to what you do these were very
small projects there were 100 to 300
thousand lines of code they're about 120
projects in the database at that time
over that period of time and all these
people were developing based on advice
and refinement and change of process we
we tried a particular process for
example we use Harlan mills's clean room
and we would see what went wrong with it
and what would write with it and how we
would change it how it evolved it was
one thing to do it on smaller projects
that were built in-house then when we
contracted out what had to be done so as
we observed it changes were made
constantly two processes being used then
there was a this experience base of
knowledge and information that just grew
and grew over time
the the software engineering lab
actually was the first group
organization to be awarded the software
process achievement award the I Triple E
SDI software process achievement award
for sustained measurable improvement
over a period of time and here with some
of the data you can see that if we look
I'm going to give you three dates 87 91
and 95 and if i take the years around
that period of time so it's so 787
really represents nineteen eighty six
seven and eight etc what would happen
was you saw decreased defect rates from
eight from seventy-five percent in the
first go-round to thirty-seven percent
in the second go-round we saw a reduced
cost fifty five percent and forty-two
percent in this so it was a continual
change improved reuse Wow in the
beginning it was it was dramatic once we
started to look we began to see that was
an easy win but it was only eight
percent in the second round because it
was not so much we could put together
there and zip so you understand this was
for ground support systems for
satellites and an independent study was
held in and it in about ninety two and
their argument with some 76 292 the
period they were looking at there was an
increase of complexity of five fold in
terms of the systems that were being
built and sent out CSC who was the
contractor in 98 became CMM level five
ISO certified based on this experience
we started that's one of the reasons we
started the fraunhofer Center to see if
we can do this with other organizations
and there's a project called sea bass
which is was an nsf-funded Institute
that began in trying to get replicate
some of the things that we had done here
so I'll talk about those if I can move
the slide okay so I'll talk first talk
about yes
very impressive do you have numbers how
actually general some improvement in
software development heard enough period
know the answer to that question yes but
you know what it's hard to get those
numbers so you're asking exactly the
right question because you don't have
the data those other people didn't
collect data I don't know not only do I
not know where they were I don't know
where they are now so that's the problem
and if the answer is they did what a
shame that we missed what they were
doing to make those improvements so sea
bass sea bass was an NSF sponsored
activity was called the incentive
empirically based software engineering
and the project goal was to enable a
decision framework and experience base
that forms the basis an infrastructure
needed to evaluate and choose among
software development technologies and
and sea bass and the research goal was
how do we evolve this empirical research
engine how do we understand better and
how to collect this data how to generate
hypotheses how to analyze and synthesize
what we've learned from particular
pieces so we could raise it to the top
and this was something run but you by
Barry BAM at Universal in California and
myself at Maryland so look the approach
was and it's just what we've don't have
talked about try and do observation and
evaluation studies of development
technologies and techniques what can we
learn about what what's in what's going
on in that process and in fact so the
topic areas for this project originally
were defect defect detection techniques
and constipate development techniques
one at both two different ends of the
spectrum is around in fact and then we
started to do some stuff with agile
systems when Laurie became part of the
the process so we tried to collect that
data and then from that data try to
build general heuristics or even
predictive models we were fancy what can
we gather how do we start to build
evidence about what's working and under
what conditions and what advice can we
give
to someone who is going to build a
system so one of the things would be the
one I talked about earlier for false of
omission and correct specification peer
reviews tend to be more effective than
functional testing on the other hand we
could build predictive models most of
you are sure know about Kokomo but
there's a model called coat cocottes
because that was the focus of the work
we were doing these are the two areas we
working in the cost of of cots tailoring
was actually a function of the number of
parameters initialize the complexity of
scriptwriting the security access
requirements etc we're able to build
actually predictive models of what
should happen when you were trying to
built use cots products the idea behind
sea bass was is to to think of it as
terms of three layers this sort of basic
research stuff that we really need to do
to to make things work building them
this offer engineering empirical
research engine and experience base what
are the right empirical methods how do
you define that experience base how to
do decision support so that it's what
you've discovered is available to people
who now can make use of it then there's
applied research and this is really
where the the risk stuff comes in you
have these ideas but let's try these
things in practice and and here the
concept of test beds comes in how do we
build test beds that we can try and
apply these things and see if they work
and and how they work and so experiment
with with in selected areas and start to
fill this experience base with more
mature empirical methods and
technologies and the top level is to try
and then use it in real projects and
start to build build this over time and
then of course there's feedback to how
we do how we might change what we're
doing and how we might modify what will
learn so there's a learning process and
here is the issue of scale up going from
small in some sense too large and basic
research to applied research to
practical applications but still
learning from those practical
applications
so I'm going to talk by talking about
the bottom level first what's the
research that we think needs to be done
how do you formulate evolving evolving
hypotheses regarding development
decisions how do you put these things in
a way that you I can give somebody
advice what they can trust and what they
can believe how do I collect good
empirical data and experiences sometimes
it's real data sometimes it's it's ad
hoc information it's out of interviews
there's all sorts there's all forms you
want to be able to use and you want to
literally use them all to gather
information you want to record
influencing variables made the point
earlier that one size doesn't fit all so
what are the variables that make it not
fit all what are the real influencing
differentiators the context variables
that change the whole effect in the
world as it's turning out then you want
to build models lessons learn your wrist
expands design support frameworks
quantitative models and tools so that's
the clear building of mullet and
knowledge building models that have as
much information in them about what to
do 12 what circumstances and then you
want to integrate them into a framework
Wow re that's really a hard problem I
mean there's a whole issue of this
technique counts find twenty percent of
the defects that points twenty percent
of the defects and guess what they're
the same twenty percent so I don't want
to use both of those in the same study
the interface of coming out of this
technique doesn't interface well into
going into the next technique so how do
I put those pieces together and then
literally testing hypotheses by
application how do you run experiments
in large organizations and in small
organizations and what things do you
need to be able to do that and most
important how do you start to package
some of the things we learned via those
techniques
oops okay what I'm going to do is I'm
going to walk you through I think it's
three or four projects that we've been
involved in to try and give you examples
okay of the various pick pieces in some
sense the NASA software engineering lab
was a full example but it's old data so
I'm going to give you some new data some
new stuff that it's been going on and
show you how we managed to creep into
each of those pieces so the first
project I'm going to talk about in fact
i'll tell you it now with the three
projects there in the talk about one is
a NASA high dependability computing
program another one is the high
performance computing program and the
third one is a clearing house project
for best practices so applied this was
actually a great project it died by the
way knowin a Surrey decided where they
were going but I was sorry because it
was a really good project and even
though we only did it in two years
you'll see you'll see what came out of
it it was NASA of course and CMU was the
lead but and there were technology
developers MIT and university of
washington in fact with technology
developers as with CMU and maryland and
USC was sort of the empiricist empirical
side of this problem so the problem from
NASA's point of view was how do you
elicit the software dependability needs
of various stakeholders and what
technology should be applied to achieve
that debt dependability
so the project goal from NASA's point of
view is how do i how do i increase the
ability of NASA to engineer highly
dependable software systems via the
development of new technologies okay
reducing risk nASA has wonderful rules
about whether in hardware technology
whether or not you can use them where
they are and their maturity scale in
terms of what's available to them but
you know you can walk in off the street
and throw in a software technique and
it's kind of ok because software is not
treated like it's a real thing it's sort
of this other thing that they do so that
was the issue here and then the research
goal was our first question was what do
you mean by dependability what is it how
do you had you can't define
dependability so and then if we develop
high tech not at I depend ability
technologies what tell us whether or not
they're effective or raise them in the
maturity scale and let us know they're
worth trying and maybe some clue about
what conditions they could be tried at
so what's nice and I'm going to use this
is more than an asset issue it says
there are really three major problems
that we need to address in this process
okay the first problem is can-can the
quality needs the understood and modeled
from NASA we said use the word
dependability but they're really talking
about quality needs what do you what do
you need to have to be true about this
project so you have to be able to elicit
that information wow how do you do that
from a stakeholder okay I remember being
on a she actually was chairing a panel
for for the FAA when they were trying to
decide about the advanced automation
system whether they should use Ada and
one of the interesting things I remember
from from the requirements for that
advanced automation system is they
wanted now I can't remember but the
exact number but it was like nine nines
or 12 9s or reliability so you go to
somebody and say okay give me the system
with 12 9s or reliability I don't even
know what you want what you mean by that
so that was question number one how do
you elicit it how do you check it's
there whatever you decided how do you
put that piece together and those
reliability those issues are usually
defined in terms of what I don't want to
have happen I don't want this to go down
I want that to go down I don't want this
to fail etc number two problem number
two what does the technology do and can
it be empirically demonstrated you may
laugh at the first statement it says I
find defects in okay and wat what kinds
of defects tell me more so I can figure
out what it is you're really doing MOS
technology say trust me it's a good it's
a good technique so let's see what
what's really happening here and very
often technology developers if you force
them into saying what what am I really
doing will say okay Phil talk in terms
of fools or anomalies this is something
you didn't want to see or it'll be a
Fulton in the design of the code they
don't talk in terms of operational stuff
like failures so first issue notices
these people are talking two totally
different languages and the third group
is the people who are now going to use
this stuff who are going to say okay I
want to understand what the user wants
and then I want to figure out which of
these techniques to put together to
solve that particular problem what
should be applied to achieve the desired
quality with the decision support and
their problem is partly understanding
how these pieces related and for those
you looked at these these are not
there's not a simple mapping here
between these two pieces so how do i how
do you put that information together so
I'm going to try in the three talk to
talk about work that needs to be done
here and here and a little bit here so
if that kit here is it so the system
user issues I'm going to use this I'm
going to talk about the UMD model it's
University of Maryland sounds like
there's really the unified model of
dependable
and I'll talk about that its use in the
NASA hdcp project how well does it the
technology work I'm going to show some
some issues out of NASA and the DARPA
high-performance computing project and
then last sister issues i'm going to
talk about developer issues this DoD
clearinghouse project
so here are the system issues how do I
elicit it how do I who do it how do I
get non functional requirements in a
consistent way across multiple
stakeholders maybe Ana Carmen
terminology that can be integrated it
how do I take advantage of previous
knowledge this is this is a hard
question asking people to tell you what
their availability requirements are what
their reliability requirements are what
their sustainability requirements are so
how do you get them to tell you that in
a common way that you can make sense out
of it because that all has to be
filtered together till it's usable so
can we build so if we can build
knowledge a knowledge base and
experience base of things that have been
used before we can then not start from
scratch every time how do i identify
compatibilities in my non functional
requirements so what we propose here was
this thing called UMD it's a
requirements engineering framework
priscilla's eliciting and modeling
quality requirements so that's the
components are that you instead of
saying here I want nine nines of
reliability in the whole system it says
cut that down let's go back and say okay
give here are the Scopes here are the
pieces what do you want reliability on
on everything are there certain
sanctions are certain functions you care
about are some need to be more
dependable than others so the first
issue is what do you want nut not what
do you want to not happen and for which
sub pieces of the system so it starts to
create a language that says well I don't
want the well give example below the
book service of something like Amazon
that's just the scope not the whole
thing I me not giving you a reliable
just I'm giving you performance here
we're talking about should have a
response time greater than 10 seconds so
that's my issue okay
it's in terms in terms of a failure if
it doesn't do that I'm going to consider
that a failure right so an issue happens
can happen but I might have tolerable
manifestations all right I can fail one
time out of 50 and i won't i won't be
horrified by by what you get but if you
fail more than that then or whenever you
fail I want you to tell me what I'm
what's supposed to happen so what's the
reaction when you do have a failure so
this says okay if a failure occurs the
system should one the user that and
recover full service within an hour so
here you can fail what in one percent of
the cases so these are the pieces and
for each piece like an issue we
differentiate failures and hazards but
you can talk about the type of failure
the availability impact the severity the
whole classification that you can do
about how do i classify this failure and
I could do the same thing for a hazard
and then I get an tell you it concerns
which scope of the main system it could
be the whole system but it could be
pieces of it yes understand the lab
requirement your soil for the bookstore
last page in terms of you're saying one
percenter users don't have service for
an hour or the entire systems not know
yet an hour no the idea let me come back
to that the idea was that I one percent
of the time that someone accesses I
don't get the right performance
requirement
okay but you said and then they get a
warning and then the full service and I
don't full service yeah in an hour yeah
what now that you're saying that I
mixture pieces and try to shrink this
down a mix two pieces you're right they
didn't make sense okay I'll carry that
example on the next slide I hopefully
right we'll see what happens the so
that's the scope okay and there may have
been an event or we didn't talk about
this event that caused this this is
especially useful when you're talking
about hazards but you can also it also
can be true for failures and it's you
know what's the type of event and
adverse condition and attack etc and and
then that issue manith the manifestation
of it is why how am I going to measure
whether or not it's it's acceptable so I
might want to mean time between failures
of a point of nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein reliability or I might
just give you some simple ordinal
measure or might say never it can never
fail this is the thing you can never
have anything happen and and then if it
does what's my trigger what's the
reaction I'm going to have so this would
say I might give you it is impact
mitigation there's recovery put that de
probably cause I want a recovery thing
and the currents reduction so in fact
what what the trigger does the reaction
does it actually allows you to add new
requirements because it says I wasn't
thinking about this but if something
happens this is what I want to have
happen so this piece of the things has
the characterizations on basic UMD
modeling concept you you start out if
you have a base of things to begin with
you have some information you can use
and then you can built you take your
context information and build that
system build your requirements and then
that can be taken back and added to and
built upon other existing kinds of
requirements so for example if you a
scoping for any number of response times
you already have some models that you
can start and change rather than invent
things from New and you can get to see
what other people have done under those
conditions then there's a tool a very
prototype tool that you can use that
will give you things like how much how
much you you were dealing with things
like availability for each surveil
ability for each service the mean time
between failures for services any kind
of data you want it can do a computation
of aggregate values of dependability
because what you'll find is different
stakeholders will give you different
answers and you've got to sort of tie
these together there's a visual
interface vqi which will say to you for
example here's a service and you had
actually no defects noted for that
certain no failures for that service so
obviously that wasn't important to you
so it reminds you where you are in that
entire process this system has been used
at JPL in fact it was used to select the
appropriate real-time java component
because of its non functional
requirements and they all did the same
function it's a question of what other
things they needed to have have done so
they were able to be specified and done
we run experiments with classes and
trying to combine various bits and
pieces how do you how do you negotiate
different different requirements so some
of it is using for example berry beams
win-win activity of trying to put
together what are the rights of
requirements okay so the second piece of
that big puzzle was how do i but now I'm
a technologist and I want to know how is
my technology were quick and it be
improved and how do I articulate the
goals of a technology that's a very
interesting question because it's very
often hard for technologists to do this
the thinking bottom up they can't tell
you precisely what it is they they
thought they were achieving but this
forces them to say okay I am really
going to find the large number of errors
of type X Y or Z
and how do I empirically demonstrate can
I show it by running it on a test bed
but here's the issue about test beds can
I take away some of the concern here by
running this on a particular test bed
and showing that it did something like
what I just said it was going to do how
do you provide feedback for improving
the technology so example evaluations
very often with the new technology is
levels of evaluation the first one is is
sometimes feasibility this is an example
of a inspections of object-oriented
designs first issue was to deal with
feasibility is it possible can people
actually use it does it make any sense
does it desert doesn't it should there
be further study okay before I spend the
money the second one is on usability
that is once it is how do I perform
things so one of the big questions
always in terms of defining a process is
level of specificity how detailed do I
make it what do I just give you a broad
stroke issues and it may depend on the
kind of person I'm dealing with which
which of those things I do and the last
piece is things like effectiveness do
they represent usable improvement to
practice now we want to bring it out and
compare it against other things what
we're doing in this process is
minimizing risk as we come down that
that scale little by little you begin to
understand whether or not this is a good
thing to try and in real life I
mentioned the test fit so let me say
something about test beds test beds I
think are extremely important and
neglected part of software engineering
and especially empirical software
engineering everybody should be testing
out their technique and it would be nice
to have it on common common test beds to
see whether or not they do work and then
what I what do I mean by a test bed is
that the infrastructure needed for
running experiments evaluating them
specific features to monitor it's used
to conduct studies to stress the
technology and demonstrate its contact
effectiveness most important i think is
to help the researcher identify strains
bounds and limits of particular
technologies and for different levels
it's an interesting thing
when it if you look at the literature
you look at a paper someone wrote about
new technology when did they say this is
great under these conditions but you
know doesn't work over here okay the
implication is it works every time all
the time for anyone who wants to use it
that's not technology that's magic and
we're in a technology business so we
really want advice on when is something
going to work and when is it not a good
idea to try my technology oops so let me
give a second example and I love this
example because again it didn't we had
used this test bed that we had built and
it was a thing called T safe three which
was a did I talk about it in the
previous one but I skip over it now I
didn't tell you what it was so t say
fizza isn't it is a part of an advanced
automation system faa type or donation
system that talks about crashes in
public and t say three because we've
been evolving it and we had to evolve it
for to deal with the particular
component we were dealing with so tific
bulton at university of california santa
barbara anima has a model checking
design for verification approach and the
techni are techniques to eliminate
synchronization errors so we said okay
let's take our existing t safe which had
been used for looking at architecture
evaluations and tried to put his his
approach and into it so the the goal was
to investigate the effectiveness of the
design apply to design for verification
approach on t safe and it was reared as
i just said so part of the test bed was
we built 40 versions of t safe source
code were created via faults eating each
one carried it's a single fault and the
falls were created to resemble possible
errors that arise in using the
concurrency control controller patterns
such as making an error while writing a
guarded command or forgetting to call a
concurrency control and method for
assessing a shared object
the results were the experimental study
resulted in number one his a side
benefit much better Fourth
classification for this particular
domain o.k weeby get bad we had to do
that and we were able to do that
identified I don't mean it's perfect but
it's certainly better than anything we
found in the literature as a matter of
fact identified strengths and weaknesses
of the technology in fact and and so
that it's the next thing that helped
improve it what tific did was based on
the errors we didn't find he what made
changes to his technology to see what we
can find them and he made a series of
changes that made it better but it turns
out there a couple of errors no matter
what he did we couldn't find so we
understood the bound we understand where
it was good okay in fact this was
presented that the automated sort of
engineering conference won best paper
award it was it was worked by tific and
people at fraunhofer like Michael
Limbaugh system development issues i'm
going to i want to raise it cuz i said
it here but i'll come back to it again
and this is the issue of given those two
things here we are I both these
requirements and Here I am somebody says
this thing to piece of technology works
how do I get those two things together
ok and I'll talk a little bit about that
in it but I wanted to bring in one more
piece I wanted to talk about this study
because for me it's especially
interesting and it's also the one we're
working on mostly now it's this idea of
the high productivity computing systems
what was the problem how do you improve
the time and cost of developing high-end
computing codes so the project goal was
to improve the buyer's ability things
comes out of DARPA so the buyer's
ability to select the the high-end
computer for the problems to be solved
based upon productivity but now here's
an interesting concept of productivity
especially for the high performance
computing people it was time to solution
is development time plus execution time
okay most IH high-performance people are
great with performance time they measure
performance in a thousand different ways
but they vary that factor I didn't know
of anyone ever asked the question so how
long's it take me to develop okay
there's a lot of folklore is in what
about OpenMP or I our mpi or Cobra for
train or so what's the best thing for me
to do the argument here was if I can get
an order of magnitude benefit in
execution time but it takes me twice as
long to develop that code or is the
payoff here how do you balance these two
pieces so we've been working mostly on
the front part development time but
integrating with the other people so how
do you develop theories hypotheses just
the things we were talking about
guidelines that allow us to characterize
evaluate predict improve how HPC
environments affect the development of
high-end computing codes so stairs here
the here are the questions which it
sound the same in any other form that is
what is the cost and benefit of applying
a particular technology a oak or a
fortran hm TC star p what are the
relationships among the technologies the
workflows the development costs the
defects the performance one of the
arguments rate that we're starting a
study on right now is there's there's an
argument that says it would be good to
to excuse me to combine MPI and OpenMP
in one program that I can use both of
them there's a lot of people go
absolutely not there a lot of people say
absolutely yes so we're looking at that
particular problem but we've looked at
problems like how much more expensive is
it to use NPR's OpenMP where you
performance especially with novices so
what are the context variables can we
build predictive models how do we do
trade-offs so just as we talked about
before it's the same process development
time experiments and now there's an
interest in novices as well as experts
because they want to know how long it
takes how how do you get novices up to
speed because there aren't enough people
to probe
these things and and what's the basis
for doing this and then we built the
same thing but here the issue is a
novice can achieve speed up in cases x
y&z but not in case is a B and C that is
what's the nature of the domain of the
problem space that I'm working in that
easier for novices due to do or not or
not easy for them to do let me just give
you a simple result that so far there
are novices who do is who do as well as
experts okay but they're the exception
because some some novices can't even get
better better performance out of
parallel code than the data of the
serial code trade-offs predictive models
what are the trade-offs between effort
and performance MPI will increase the
development effort by such and such
percent and increase the performance by
z % / openmp what are those numbers and
for what under what conditions is that
statement true for which of those
programming models as it does that make
sense ok where our test beds all these
nice things we have lots of assignments
we have at classes we have run
experiments and I think it's like eight
nine universities the experiments are in
classes run by people in high
performance computing okay and then we
have looked at complex compact
applications and then actually full
scale applications we've interacted with
the five ASCII centers who had to say
illinois-chicago Utah Stanford and
Caltech so how do they build and what's
the effect of that we take some of the
early stuff we've learned to put into
that larger piece what are we doing
we're building experiment packages I
mean our eventual goal would be to give
this to organizations that they can do
this data collection of their own and
see whether they can put pieces together
so it's everything from giving example
programming props i did that room giving
example programming problems to
experimental artifacts to data
collection software so that whether
you're doing classroom empirical studies
all these people can gain
something out of what it is they're
they're dealing with there are a lot of
problems in this because it's most most
University stuff is anonymity of data
there's things you have to do a few this
may be hard to believe but it's true if
you're running an experiment a software
experiment with a class you have to fill
out all these forms promise that they're
not dying or you're not doing anything
terrible to them never university has
them and some of them you have to
profess us take a course so we've been
lucky everyone's gone gone along with us
but it's it's not a simple process in
fact here the studies we've done in fact
there's one going on another one going
on this semester at University of
Maryland and one at the University of
Hawaii as a matter of fact where we were
looking at specifically at defects
classes of defects and that did commit
it and can we modify how many defects
get done based on the kind of training
for example if you if you teach them
about specific defect patterns in
high-performance computing do they start
to do a better job okay last last
project I want to talk about is the
Clearinghouse project and this is where
I wanted to come back to that issue of
how do you package this stuff how does
someone figure out what to do when
you've told them the two bits and pieces
so the project goal here was to populate
an experience base for acquisition best
practices so it's I don't I don't have a
good example that goes from bidding to
end but here's here's the technology
behind this is exactly what you need for
defining context impact and impact
attributes allowing users to understand
the effects of applying the processes
based on the best empirical evidence
available so it's sort of saying let's
think this way before I pick something I
want to see what happened who's used
this when how what happened ok so the
research goal here is to define a
repeatable model-based empirical
evidence vetting process enabling
different people to create profiles
consistent and to be able to integrate
new evidence so the concept here ok is
that people will be putting in best
practices the repository best practice
handling there will be
they'll be look there'll be people see
information handle it as I want to go
next who are worrying about the
identification the qualification and of
information Alice's synthesis validation
packaging taking that data analyzing and
synthesizing it essentially there
there's a set of operations that need to
be done and then there's the users who
committed with to an intelligent front
end and say what it is they need to have
done so i can hit fancy now so be best
practice clearinghouse recommendations
based on evidence from real programs and
it can be come from it comes from
publications from interviews and
feedback with users from vetted experts
guidebooks and standards to this whole
ways of collecting evidence hey every
summer kick of it can be anecdotal some
of it can be because you have really
good empirical study okay and then you
say what your source is how trustable is
that source you rate it how the context
is used by a safety-critical program in
a DoD environment Honor Warfighter
because that's what I'm building let's
say and I want to know if anybody's been
doing it in that context did it increase
or reduce cost and quality and schedule
okay so behind the scenes we have a
summary here's where the work part comes
in someone does this summary where the
practice was was successfully applied
what had helped and the cost what had
helped and what the cost was and how to
get started and then once that summer is
written a team that's what that summary
is about and vets the processing the
evidence
so that's the internal view the userview
who's going to now make use of this says
okay help me find a practice to reduce
schedule I'm an acquisition manager on a
safety-critical program okay so summery
who's who is used it for safety-critical
program before for this particular
process that I'm looking at I might have
two groups there are two places that
have a higher level of evidence that's
the end for what it is I'm looking at
this is now being used by the Department
of the defense acquisition University to
do teaching in acquisition processes
okay let me get back to the research
think of all the things I've said and
where the research lies I said we really
need research and doing doing this doing
better jobs of this this is really what
you want to be able to do someone's a
bill to go say here's my problem tell me
the best things to use and and give me a
confidence level I'm nervous about this
but this is brow everybody's used it
exactly what you were doing that it may
get gave them more costs but they got
better whatever better quality there's
the issue of hypotheses we're building
all these hypotheses how do you put them
together and had as new evidence build
on top of it for the HP CS project we
have a prototype experience base which
talks about hypotheses and evidence and
change so that you can follow the trail
of what information is going but I want
that more abstracted we're worrying
about context variables all the time
what are the things when we when we're
running we have I said there's actually
about 20 experiments run over different
universities what causes certain things
to happen what wide it's why why did we
get different results from different
studies not a question are trying to say
the same thing and trying to understand
what caused these strange things to
happen so let me summarize I'm saying
measure measurement is fundamental to
any engineering science hopefully you
all believe that
users user needs must be made explicit
and therefore we have to build
measurable models of what we mean by
quality by the various qualities as I
said whether its availability of
sustainability reliability security
safety it doesn't matter what is it you
want to be able to say in organizations
have different characteristics goals
cultures there isn't a one-size-fits-all
there isn't like a 2 2 sizes fit or
there's like a an enormous number of
sizes to be able to put the pieces
together and stakeholders have very
different needs the same system and you
got to be able to understand what those
needs are and how you ameliorate them so
that they look consistent process is a
variable that's the biggest thing I've
been saying this for years and it's
really a hard thing and years ago you go
into a company would say here's our book
on software development I don't care
whether we're building toasters or
satellites yes huh here's how we build
the software for them you wouldn't see
the same book saying hey we're building
toasters here's our hardware techniques
in here and we're building satellites
here's our software is our hardware
techniques well who's the same book so
there's a there's a confusion here about
what needs to be done but process is a
variable needs to be configured for the
project that you're dealing with I think
we've gotten better about that but
things like CNM for example early onward
it was really about his here is the
process rather than what's your problem
and you could optimize a process
independent how does that make sense
independent of its effect on the product
we need to learn from our experiences
and that doesn't mean I learned from my
experience I mean you'll learn from my
experience and then someone analyzes and
synthesizes and says we can begin to
build core competencies of what we know
works under what conditions in the idea
of software core competency is a really
critical one it's really the idea why
the experience factory with its built on
the idea we need to build software core
competence
they represent specific context there
are a lot of context but wouldn't in one
organization you've dropped out the
majority of the context because those
things will turn out to be the same so
you only have to build it for the
organization or for the product and this
is from the research point of the
interaction with various industrial
government and academic organizations is
important to understand the problems
okay this isn't a small simple problem
physics use the term big science I mean
this is big science because you can't do
it in your office alone you can't do it
without having lots of stuff going on
that you can manipulate and look at and
see what's happening under all those
pieces if we build the ultimate models
but organizations only need to build
their models okay and to expand
potential competencies we need to pop
partner there's also there's all worries
about the human element there's worries
about how do I deal with the hardware
technologies how do I deal with the
domain I mean one of the things I've
learned from this the domain makes
enormous amount of difference about what
you do and how you do it because the
cultures may be different number one
number two the problems really are
different when we working with hpcs the
problems they deal with us so different
I mean you know use your restroom
clashes they don't worry about
performance it's a whole different
mindset about what you're doing and how
you go about doing it so last slide we
need to build an empirical research
engine for software engineering we
begged borrowed and stolen techniques
we've modified them tailored them put
them together as best we can but this
this this needs to be expanded here's
the thing I think we haven't invested in
a building test beds okay we have some
test beds here's the question who's
supporting them who's keeping them going
we have set the data from a variety of
sources and people always say oh can I
get that it will I I don't have the
money to give it to you to package it
for you to do all the things you need to
do this is not something that people
think about in the software domain
because when we don't have an imperial
component in general we want to build
decision support systems Oh build
product models that allow us to make
trade-off decisions okay the idea that
you can have faster better cheaper and
and secure and safety all for the same
cost you know I just wow what were you
thinking what was anybody thinking when
when when they would talk in that way
how do I trade off I'll give you more of
this but you got to give me some of that
had it but we don't even have a basis
for making those decisions and we use a
decision support systems of invested
empirical advice for selecting the right
processes and last issue is use
empirical study to test and evolve
technologies for their appropriateness
that's mostly what I talked about but
it's a part of the larger larger scheme
we you need to do that the idea that you
can publish a tech he'll if I scent of a
goober research publisher technology
that's never been tried is an amazement
to me wow what is that is that even mean
who said that was a good idea I don't
mean you have to have a full-blown
experiment you have to at least a
feasibility study that it could run in
something happened when you did it you
applied it somewhere you have to have
great controls then you can start to
introduce controls but do number one
first and on that note and done thank
you
yes briefly mixture once and thoroughly
besides which is agile stuff which is
documentation like one of the problems
I've had maybe no of studies I don't
know of is where your inspections and
test studies but what people ask me well
how does pair programming compared with
software inspections there are some
people working on that that very
specific question but I don't know about
publications here I know I know Laurey
Williams is working on that and there's
some interest it at the fraunhofer in
Germany we're worrying about that issue
about how do you how do you may help
make those decisions one of the problems
with a lot of empirical work is has been
to piecemeal and people do little pieces
because it to be honest most most
experimental work turns out to be
opportunistic I have the opportunity to
run the study I'll do this little piece
wee bit did a study back in the late 70s
that was I think was there one of the
best studies we ever did and sort of
like that was it remember in fact I
remember people saying as well you
answered that question that would just
say something like that we did one study
but then there wasn't a community we now
have a community we have this group this
leading I CERN which started we're in
our 12th meeting and actually started by
a group who were all X Marylanders had
come and spend some time left and said
we need to talk about sharing more
common things and we're finally getting
there I think people are replicating
each other's experiments what a great
what an incredible idea and so we're
still growing I'm horrified if I
supposed to give a keynote in two weeks
which I haven't prepared yet but it's
really to say what what was true 20
years ago what's true now because we
wrote a paper 20 years ago but was the
state-of-the-art nipping / what's true
now and what's going to be happening
what do we expect to happen
years were you given at home in any say
Z in the international software
engineering symposium software
engineering staff engineering pozos and
it's going to be in Rio de Janeiro so
it's a hard question I mean I predicting
the future is really hard someone asked
me 20 years ago that where we be I would
have been wrong I would have thought
you've been much further along but we
have a community we have people who are
working on this part of is the money we
don't have the kind of support really
necessary have a journaling empirical
software engineering journal which just
got its impact rating and in the
software engineering domain we're number
three after TSE and and tosin so I was
startled because they did the study of
us who know where all we in this process
so we were at jss and all the other
journals who just wow great so there's
an interest someone wants people want to
know this stuff they want to know what's
going on and that's really great I
remember giving a lecture in listen
people going what is it why is he
talking about this some of you may have
been saying that now but why is he
talking about this but it's it's got to
happen one of the reasons I came here to
be honest is to promote this to get
people caring about it to say if you're
not doing this what the heck could you
possibly be thinking and doing we're not
we're never going to bring software
development out of the dark ages until
we turn it into an engineering
discipline it's that first statement
thats off engineering is about
engineering wasn't a casual statement
it's well say it but it's become so
trite we really are about engineering we
really are about trade-offs we really
are about building models that you can
do things really are about an engineer
software engineering handbook the
letting go and say under what conditions
do something work and not where's my
evidence and you know very often you'll
get an answer this is well you can't
answer it perfectly for me now I don't
know well we gotta build do a lot of
work before we can answer that and maybe
we'll never answer it perfectly but will
always be able to answer it better than
we can now
so that's my sales pitch yes so you
mentioned again you touched on a
verbally about the human element and in
early studies were like 10 to 1
differences between people in
productivity and defect rates and that's
always seemed to really hurt empirical
studies because any small study of a
small group of people just doesn't tell
you anything because because there's
such a variance the variance is so high
just depends on the question you're
asking ok so so and those things that
involve something yeah so let's come
back if it's about feasibility okay you
give up even though yeah okay I can do
usability can someone use this how can I
make it more meaningful now what you're
saying is what's the story about with
effect and then you have to be more
careful in your experiments and how you
put the pieces together and and there
are lots of things most of our things
are small groups but you there are
techniques where you can do sort of
pseudo randomization and then in fact
what we typically do is we great people
from top to bottom and then we literally
do one of these this group that group
this group that group this group that
group and then we see what happens
across that process it's not great but
it's it's trying to get at what's going
on but we're also interested in that
question what is the variation that's
especially a question the high
performance computing project can we get
people to to reach the top
so we have to maybe change the question
can't just say oh we throw you all in
the same part now we want to know
because 11 cap when characteristic is
dominating the others the idea of the
experience base is this idea of I mean
think it from a corporate point of view
every time somebody leaves your
organization they they walk away with
valuable knowledge okay and how do i how
do i own that how did I steal it so it's
available to everybody okay we just lost
somebody at the fraunhofer and someone
said oh it out a bit that person had
enormous amount of knowledge about our
business what we do whoo I thought that
was a terrible thing so the issue is how
do we capture that how do we make sure
that we don't lose it may not get it
exactly if that person has it but you
can take pieces of it that makes sense
for the organization to do something
are there any other companies besides
you know academics and government
organizations that are
this some work being done at Dom look I
see there's some stuff motorola was
doing some stuff it wasn't consulting at
least I've given talks I don't always
know to be perfectly honest study but
people using some of the things you've
done I have the if I'm not dealing with
them directly I i did a little stuff
with Don the crisis and did some stuff
with Motorola it so I know a little bit
about what goes on in some cases but
sometimes I have no idea closest
Microsoft has to this is our work in
security
but we're better about building
knowledge bases in general I want to
call it an experience base because I
don't think we're quite at the level
that you are it was security we have a
apartment gates made a big speech and
2002 and created spent a lot of money
creating the department to the managed
security across the business I it's a
great that's a great thing to do I mean
it really is I is a bad example I always
think back in the 1870s of IBM and
things like operating systems as well as
president one near and dear to the heart
of Microsoft and if anybody had a wealth
of knowledge about how to build an
operating system it was them but they
didn't package it they didn't considered
it a core competence okay
no ain't what happened so there are all
kinds of things like that that if you
don't know you got to understand what's
important but you gotta build knowledge
of what you do because it's the valuable
piece it's our problem within company
walls not this unimportance this is hard
packaging the knowledge is one thing
dissemination is incredibly difficult
well that's why i say that left peaceful
after sending that information making
good user interfaces I mean the way that
system works I'd have time to show you
all of it although i think i have i can
get a demo you you go in you say Who am
I you know he has here's my
characteristics of things that interest
me and then you can go in and it'll
it'll try and find things closest to
what you care about and and and
represent your contacts for you it's
still terribly primitive but it's it's a
start at doing this as we need a lot
more work and looking at those things
how do you do that vetting I mean you
actually did it actually rates those
things here was a you know journal
article by people who used it in their
environment and collect the date and
came to the result wow that gets a good
rating we talked to this guy he said
such and such well you know we couldn't
even control the context variables for
him because he didn't know them that's a
very different thing but I that's
something it's better than not having
anything and you start to build this
knowledge I mean one of the things
that's true oh is about the experience
basis as you get smarter and you have
work knowledge you start to throw old
stuff away this is not a it's not a
repository okay it's it's a living thing
that constantly represents our best
knowledge about what goes on here
yes
ok